[Musica]
Salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale è
il canale di lo zio io un ragazzo che fa
dei video veramente molto molto
divertenti diciamo abbastanza originali
cioè molto semplici ma molto molto molto
divertenti che vi consiglio di andare a
vedere perché meritano davvero il canale
come al solito è nelle informazioni di
questo video detto questo iniziamo ed è
di nuovo so bed It's so
good il sobit Good che voglio recensire
oggi è killer clown from ers Space
Esatto Killer clown from ers Space è un
horror del 1987 scritto e diretto dai
fratelli chiodo nome curioso e papà
martello quando torna a
casa Fatemi un favore quando faccio
queste battute fermatemi devo dire la
verità questo film Mi è piaciuto un
sacco pensavo di trovarmi di fronte al
solito filmaccio trash che pian piano
diventa Un cult in realtà Questo film è
diventato un cult perché almeno Secondo
me È divertentissimo perché questo film
non è trash perché ci sono errori
effetti speciali orribili Anzi tutto il
contrario è proprio il contenuto fatto
apposta che rende questo film trash
voglio dire Killer clown from ers Space
tradotto vuol dire clown assassini dallo
spazio profondo Sicuramente non è un
film neorealista e siccome mi è piaciuto
ho trovato molto difficile stilare una
lista di cinque punti che potrebbero
essere quelli i motivi per cui guardare
il film semplicemente perché non ci sono
cinque punti tutto il film è da guardare
Quindi cercherò di raccontarvi le cose
che mi sono piaciute di più la trama è
molto semplice un gruppo di alieni barra
clown invadono la terra e scendono in
una cittadina americana alcuni
sopravvissuti di questa cittadina poi si
vendicheranno fine quello che rendeva
secondo me il film spettacolare erano
tutte quelle piccole cose che mi
facevano dire ma è ovvio ovviamente non
potrebbe essere altrimenti Ma è meglio
se vi faccio degli esempi atterrano con
un tendone da circo ovviamente uccidono
le persone trasformandole in bozzoli di
zucchero filato ma è ovvio e hanno delle
Armi che sparano proiettili di popcorn
non potrebbe essere altrimenti e già a
questo punto del film riesce a capire
che tutto è raccontato in una maniera
molto molto ironica è come se questo
film fosse la parodia di tutti gli altri
film che sono usciti negli anni 80 tipo
la guerra di mondi l'invasion degli
Ultracorpi e soprattutto Blob Il fluido
mortale Allora io le genialate che ci
sono nel film non ve le vorrei dire
tutte perché vi spoileri buona parte del
divertimento Però per curiosità ve ne
dico due ma giusto due per inseguire gli
umani gli alieni clown con un palloncino
creano un cagnolino che fiuta le
tracce
[Musica]
Madonna è fottutamente geniale ma mai
quanto l'uccisione
con che ci volete fare con quelle torte
figliole Esatto le torte in faccia
tirano talmente tante torte in faccia
quella persona che diventa un cumulo di
panna come ciliegina sulla torta gli
mettono una ciliegia in testa Se siete
ancora seduti a guardare questa
recensione Siete degli idioti Spero
siate corsi il più velocemente possibile
per procurarvi questo film Anche perché
recentemente tra virgolette cioè da
qualche anno è stato riproposto in DVD
Quindi non avete nessuna scusa per non
andarlo a vedere Per chi volesse ancora
ascoltare questa recensione parliamo un
po' degli aspetti tecnici La regia è
molto buona molto semplice niente di
assurdamente spettacolare ma fa il suo
lavoro invece devo elogiare abbastanza
gli effetti speciali la scena
dell'uccisione delle ombre credo che me
la ricorderò per il resto della mia vita
In pratica c'è un pagliaccio che con le
mani Proietta delle ombre contro il muro
Quando
[Musica]
[Applauso]
all'improvviso Nona a credere ai miei
occhi
visto io ve l'avevo detto di correre ad
andare a vedere il film adesso mi avete
fatto spoilerare una delle più belle
scene che c'è nel film mi dispiace per
voi No scherzo però di scene così il
film ne è veramente pieno c'è stata però
una scena che mi ha ricordato che questo
è anche un film horror In pratica un
Clown viene arrestato poi riesce a
fuggire dalla prigione e ad un certo
punto usa un poliziotto come
marionetta vogliamo soltanto
ucciderti
Santa svacca o i brividi perché quella
scena esce fuori dopo un'ora di
divertimento ci rimane male in positivo
però i personaggi del film sono
caratterizzati in modo un po' strano
cioè i protagonisti sono un po' anonimi
mentre i personaggi secondari sono fin
troppo caratterizzati quasi ad essere
stereotipati senza il quasi tipo I
mitici fratelli Terenzi Loro sono dei
vendit di gelati che guidano un camion
con sopra la testa di un Clown forza
fatti un break rinfrescate quei baci
ardenti con i nostri gelati al gusto di
frutta lampone fragola limone ananas
banana diteci solo che gusto e che
misura vi accontenteremo Che palle
prendete i gelati e andate al diavolo vi
lascio immaginare come andrà a finire
con loro Ah è così Muoviti pedala
abbiamo altro da fare poi c'è il solito
poliziotto rompipalle della centrale di
polizia che pensa che tutti si stiano
inventando la storia dei clown non crede
a nessuno chiama la polizia di stato e
chiedi aiuto sono pagliacci uccidono la
gente passa Ok Fammi capire bene Dici
che sono clowns e che tu li hai visti
ora Dave stai a sentire me [__] tu a
i tuoi amici drogati sono stupo di
essere trattato in questa maniera lo so
che cosa cercate di fare di vedermi
crollare di strapparmi le dimissioni Beh
ci vorrà molto di più di una trovata
come questa Per costringere Kurt Mune e
a gettare la spugna chiaro perciò
[__] passo fin quando non ci
lascia le
penne Oh sì Mentre ripeto i due
protagonisti che dovrebbero essere
quelli più caratterizzati sono
abbastanza anonimi andiamo a vedere
dov'è su Non essere sciocca Deby è una
perdita di tempo sarà migliaia di miglia
Da qua ci passeremo la notte non dire
fesserie l'hai visto con i tuoi occhi è
sceso dietro la collina e non è così
lontano da qua ma nulla che dia troppo
fastidio e questo è killer clown from
Space so che la recensione non è proprio
una recensione normale ma volevo
veramente farvi conoscere questo film
perché merita tantissimo il film è
veramente spettacolare e non vi ho detto
tante altre cose geniali perché non
volevo spoilerarvi tutto cioè volevo
lasciarvi il piacere di scoprire che i
pagliacci muoiono soltanto se gli fai
esplodere il naso e loro esplodono in
una marea di fuochi d'artificio e
coriandoli oppure che alla fine devono
sconfiggere clown Zilla che è un Clown
gigantesco che distrugge tutto non
volevo spoilerarvi più di
tanto
merda quindi vi ringrazio per tutti gli
iscritti di tutti i commenti Tutti i
complimenti che mi fate ringrazio anche
chi acquista le mie magliette come avete
potuto vedere Ne ho messa una di
katamari ma quella l'ho creata per me
perché volevo una maglietta di katamari
e quella mi sembrava una cosa carina ho
visto che un paio di persone anche
l'hanno comprata quindi vi ringrazio e
lì se la volete e mi scuso e mi scuso
per il ritardo della recensione e
soprattutto che la recensione poi uscita
in ritardo questa qua non sia proprio
una recensione delle migliori ma eh è
estate c'è stata una botta di vita
sociale che non mi aspettavo e no Le
solite cose dell'estate Quindi se le
recensioni arriveranno un po' in ritardo
Mi scuso ma dalle prossime saranno più o
meno normali quindi vi ringrazio e ci
vediamo ad una prossima
recensione che
cazzo
CH